[Musique]
maintenant c'est aux romains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
avant
particulièrement dans cette musique 27
ans de carrière 30 millions de disques
vendus
quatre grands miroirs trois brit awards
un big up
[Musique]
vraiment génial
que ce groupe puisse venir avec moi
partout j'ai
[Applaudissements]
par exemple si je
peux jouer alors aujourd'hui s'il vous
revenez avec un dixième album intitulé
stone date où vous reprenez des mariages
frank sinatra des lapidiales de wright
charles de nina simone
on va en parler mais avant ça je vais
faire un petit flashback alors vous êtes
mais le 19 février 1963 à londres sous
le nom de nri olusegun olumide adelo
samuel can you tell it clean yucel à
quoi commencer ça fait avec élégance
alors vos parents était nigérian
immigrés en angleterre mais vous avez
aussi des origines brésiliennes
oui mon grand tu es ce que vous savez
dire magli faille qu
ils m'avaient magnifique magnifique
ça
[Applaudissements]
résister c'est vraiment fascinant
si c'est
oui là ah oui là bas mais je vois alors
peu de temps après votre naissance vous
est envoyé dans une famille d'accueil
qui s'appelle les schooling la vie est
belle sauf qu'à quatre ans votre mère
biologique veut vous récupérez et vous
n'avez jamais vu votre mère biologique
et vous êtes surpris de la voir vous
êtes surpris par le noir de sa peau
parce que vous n'aviez pas conscience à
l'époque de votre négritude vous viviez
avec des blancs etc envoyez votre merde
a avoué les
faits
est ce que c'est vrai so
surpris
logique était en
travaux de
white dans un quartier plutôt blanc
c'est vrai que la bouteille tout ça
aussi voir idée d aller est le fait
qu'en fait ça u11 faire cela sur la
vision du monde que je
en raison de cela
finalement j'ai été élevé de manière à
ne jamais voir les couleurs alors vous
retrouvez votre soeur schooling demande
la famille schooling en 2007 ont
beaucoup d'années plus tard chez oprah
winfrey ça c'est quand même
extraordinaire
retourner chez vos parents biologiques
c'est pas facile la vie hein c'est des
coups de poing des coups de fouet des
coups de ceinture puisque votre père est
très violent et heureusement il ya la
soul music et votre mère etc ou de la
soul music que la radio en fabriquant
des perruques parce que c'est son métier
j'ai commencé à chanter
je n'avais jamais imaginé devenir
musicien
et je ne chantais jamais à la maison
celui qui vous a aidé à devenir un
chanteur c'est mr rennes qui était votre
professeur de musique oui et il adorait
votre voix et un jour et vous dis un
concert à l'école tu devrais chanter
vous montez sur scène et finalement ça
se passe très bien wahaha à la clé
mais en fait c'est lui que j'ai beaucoup
aimé je l'admiré énormément et où est ce
qu il était cool et voisins
c'est un sénateur et il était devenu un
professeur
tous les profs voulais être comme lui
vous êtes comme lui donc c'était 5 et
ils changeraient est en fait je me suis
mis à chanter parce que je voulais lui
reçoit alors à l'âge de 15 ans vous
quittez la tyrannie paternelle pour
vivre dans la rue si revivez
la tyrannie de mon père
français c'est vraiment très
mélodramatique
à l'âge des oiseaux
j'appelle at il dit
et vous vous échapper dans l'erreur
après leurs chants textes ordinaire
qu'elle tragique c'était tragique
ici la voiture et on dirait que vous
n'avez pas besoin de moi pour vous faire
allumer non mais tout va bien je suis
très heureux d'avoir si le saumon
plateau
c'est vrai que non mais à l'époque je
vivais dans le métro où vivait dans la
rue vous en ai squat vivait dans
l'angoissé
si je regarde la vie que j'ai maintenant
ça tout ça je me dis
faites
par les dirigeants
parce que tout cela ne m'a amené à ce
qu'il se passe aujourd'hui est là
mesdames messieurs il ya un miracle
vous avez 23 ans quand votre petite amie
vous entend chanter
et trouve que vous chantez très très
bien et elle vous offre du matériel
revient pour bien
je vous écouterai comment
allez-vous la taille du multitâche et là
vous rencontrer des musiciens à londres
vous partez d'ailleurs après en asie au
japon
je vais y rester un an et quand vous
revenez en europe vous rencontrez
adamski et vous enregistrer
ça
sport
m
oh
le palais
alors ça c'est eric alain michelis
ensuite vous êtes seul pour faire ça
[Musique]
c'est pas
et
1994 c'est la chanson 2 batman forever
c'est ça
ok
où
je fais
m
et
et en 2009 avec mylène farmer c'est ça
[Musique]
oui
voilà
sow
c
e
et en 2003 ses stars
[Musique]
d
ma
omar
tél
non mais
et aujourd'hui si vous revenez avec un
nouvel album qui s'appelle standard que
vous avez enregistré à los angeles avec
un orchestre live et on écoute quatre
morceaux de l'album mais tout l'album et
bien franchement on y va à fond
[Musique]
non
je
[Musique]
non et non
attraction
toi
il
insatisfait
dans son ouvrage
est un
à
j'adorais ce qui me
sma
[Musique]
wen jiabao
c'est mesquin
uk pas
et
tout cela
au
fond
de la cour
c'est ce week end en brisgau
les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
z ou bien c'est juste une question
d'heures swan question before you leave
je voudrais savoir
les cicatrices everybody wants to
where does it came from busan bien
websense pas bien vieux proverbe dit que
les cicatrices sont comme des tatouages
mme avec des histoires plus intéressante
donc des gènes proviennent d'une maladie
loupé le lupus
disto id
voilà quand j'avais 23 ans
après en
à peu près bien
vite avec dams qui la première e je
pense que vous avez des
goûts
bien que je suis sorti indemne
enregistrements il avait deux fosses de
jeune fille de l'autre côté de la rue
il y en a eu et cela dit c'est lui c'est
lui qui adamski content parce qu'il
s'est jeté à l'eau et l'autre a dit non
non non c'est pas lui c'est pas possible
mais si regardez cicatrice
est donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que
au début comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
c'est quelque chose qui a été difficile
pour moi au départ
et au final c'est devenu ma signature
le projet
l'aspect fun
quand vous étiez avec heidi klum vous
étiez un couple parfait vous étiez le
couple idéal
oui il ya vu à travers vos yeux your
eyes wide shut why should i must c'est
la vie pour les arts
et ce
white au droit qui commet
il vient mille réponses apportées dans
cette
[Rires]
pour ça qu'ils étaient allemands
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
dès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui ouais ouais
on
va
deux mois
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
m
et
[Applaudissements]
il est
et
est
m
oui
doucement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la rue
[Musique]
yannick bien connu
bon appétit
[Musique]
salut les terriens et samedi
[Applaudissements]
la golfeuse
si l'accord du là
oui j
alors ma vie
alors premier terriens indiqué ce soir
l'un des deux grands cars de l'histoire
mais lui est mieux habillée c'est karl
lagerfeld
et c'est encore du nabro soir vous êtes
brésilienne vous allez donc pouvoir ce
soir répondre à la question qu'on se
pose tous en fête au sujet des
brésiliennes est ce qu'on doit bien
monsieur ou madame
[Musique]
squeeze bonsoir
9 millions d'abonnés sur sa chaîne
youtube 4 milliard de vues
[Applaudissements]
alors ils voulaient absolument visiter
un studio de télévision avant de faire
disparaître la télévision c'est squeeze
en p3 après alex vizorek nous acquérons
notre therion du samedi soir ce soir
samia maktouf
le caveau 4 né dans un milieu modeste
est devenu une star du barreau en
défendant aussi bien des victimes du
terrorisme que des clients sulfureux
comme ziad takeddine où le couple ben
ali voilà l'émission s'appelle salut les
terriens le groupe est vraiment
tranquille et le hashtag
slt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant voici mon cdd comme blida
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va tirer très bien là et content
alors par contre qui vous fait penser à
quelqu'un mais j'arrive pas à retrouver
qui je cherche de l'hôpital à moi je
fais comme vous je mets le monde
d'autres non mais voilà se passe pas
très bien fait bon ok on a deux
spécialistes de la mode ce soit là un
accent allemand l'autre à l'accent
brésilien ce qu'une émission de télé là
c'est le marché de clignancourt nantes
non mais un grand couturier est une
styliste si c'est pas un appel du pied
pour changer de look satirique vous
allez pas rester en noir toute votre vie
comme ça la fille car il sait ce qu'il
fait quand même nom il ya une petite
touche de blanc louis saha thirith et le
seul quand il va en enterrement ils
s'habillent en blanc voilà c'est très
pien notre premier invité si on se
balade avec lui dans la rue ça peut
créer une émeute surtout à la sortie
d'un collège non c'est pas michel
fourniret c'est squeeze
alors poésie que youtube heures voilà
évidemment un thierry vous fiez pas aux
apparences c'est pas parce que derrière
son physique juvénile de stagiaires et
ben se cache un patron de chaîne et oui
les temps changent avant c'était rémy
pfimlin maintenance et squeeze
c'est mieux c'est mieux non plus on dit
toujours que les français sont fainéants
c'est faux et squeeze et a démarré les
vidéos à 13 ans je crois c'est sa
médaille a créé la première chaîne
youtube à 15 ans à 17 ans il a eu son
million d'abonnés c'est le troisième
francophones aujourd'hui sur youtube le
plus suivi avec 9 millions d'abonnés et
tout ça sans avoir jamais posé aucune
sextape bravo steevy
[Applaudissements]
et faut pas avoir de mépris pour les
youtuber parce que c'est un vrai métier
c'est comme animateur télé c'est non
seulement un bon exemple mais va oui
alors lui il se filme entre autres en
train de jouer aux jeux vidéo et les
gens regardent et alors voilà je
rappelle qu'il ya bien des débiles qui
arrière d'autres débile se faire chier
autour d'une piscine à cancun et faire
des fautes de français sur nrj 12
9 millions d'abonnés l'opinion ça veut
dire que même si les deux tiers de ses
abonnés regardent ce soir salut les
terriens offert une audience digne d'un
match de foot de l'équipe de france 2 ou
capitaine marleau sur france 3 ça
cartonne non mais c'est cette vieille
technique d'invités de youtube en
espérant toute la communauté regarde en
général ça marche ça marche pas parce
que la communauté de squeeze n'a pas à
la télé je n'aime pas ce que c'est là
dont moi je propose qu'il faut utiliser
les mêmes moyens entre autres que
squeeze on va faire aurait utilisé snap
châtelain n'a pas à
huy progrès sénat elle n'a pas là bien
fait rire laurent éclairé des petites
fleurs c'est pas mal voilà
y'a les nôtres invités suivants
commencent toutes ses phrases par non
mais là ça va pas du tout faut tout
changer c'est l'horreur non c'est pas
emmanuel macron ce cristina cordula bon
brésilienne talentueux le style est
heureusement voilà red rose gagnent des
parts non il n'y aura pas de vente sur
les travestis brésilien on n'a pas les
couilles contrairement à vous vraiment
insensé
[Applaudissements]
non mais et selon un sondage christina
s'est fait partie des animatrices les
plus sympas du paf même temps c'est
normal et ce qu'ils avaient un doute et
relooke des gens gratos avec les twins
m6 évidemment c'est la plus sympa non ça
c'est une jeune mariée voilà qu'elle est
mariée trois fois avec le même homme une
fois singapour une fois qui a pris une
fois au brésil la gueule des invités
quand ils ont dû mettre dans la cagnotte
à la fin trois fois mais moi j'ai des
potes qui sont mariés l'été dernier à
avignon j'apprends de billets sncf ça
m'a fait chier singapour qui a pris rio
c'était un mariage c'est un trek sans
déconner sba
et pour finir thierry il fait partie de
ces grands qui restent cachés derrière
leurs lunettes de soleil non pas par
snobisme mais pour mieux et pied sans
être pris il sait mieux que personne
mettre les femmes en valeur c'est
monsieur karl lagerfeld
cela tient il existe encore trois grands
mystères non résolus la mort de kennedy
ouais que se cache-t-il derrière le
chapeau de geneviève de fontenay et que
se cachent ils derrière les lunettes de
karl lagerfeld des le mur
non mais karl qui a travaillé avec les
plus grands ou là il a collaboré avec
h&m coca cola optic 2000 magnum
volkswagen s'est passé mais c'est un
caddie un lacet non il a déclaré moi je
jette l'argent il faut que ça sort par
la fenêtre pour que ça re rentrer par la
porte juste est ce que vous pouvez me
donner votre adresse pour que je reste
sous votre fenêtre s'il vous plaît
bon j'y vais je vous souhaite une bonne
émission
entre d'ici la semaine prochaine
et d'ici là c'est une toile
les rapports mesdames messieurs on passe
à notre grand invité d'honneur de la
semaine
[Musique]
car à peine revanche soir
preuve on peut très bien ne pas vieillir
c'est juste une question de volonté karl
lagerfeld ami
ça va karl très bien merci
comment vache ou pet shop est pas très
bien elle est tombée malade cette nuit
parce qu'elle avait trop mal j'ai mes
fans depuis ça va
est ce que justement est ce que je
souhaite est devenu vegan à non non ça
s'est passé aux gens non alors j'ai
toujours de la ville et la viande du
poisson et vous est-ce que vous êtes
devenu vegan car non non pas vraiment
mais je ne suis pas un fanatique de
viande vrai il faut surtout pas que ça
ressemble à ce que ça a été dans la vie
voilà bon pas grave moi je peux pas
couper dans un steak dans ce cas la
traîne face au fus chirurgie vous avez
dit des fois quand je passe devant une
boucherie gens alors on me away mais ça
remonte à mon enfance que le passé mon
enfance à la campagne on dirait pas dans
une ferme modèle que mon père à vie
puisque mon père avait des usines les
condensés donc on avait une ferme modèle
et un jour je passe comme une arrière
cour de cette ferme immense il était en
train de tuer un cochon il possède et
elle crie je n'ai pas pu manger de la
viande d avoir 7-8 ans alors je pète
fait la une des magazines choupette fait
des pubs choupette gagne 3 millions
d'euros par an il a gagné plus d'argent
tu saches alcantara manga
spec est fatigué à ne le sait pas elle
ce
n est pas fatigué sous traite d'enfants
non non non non elle dort tout le temps
et elle a toujours eu quelqu'un avec
elle elle est jamais seul annoncé le
centre de la vie chez moi elle a combien
de personnes son service je prête après
je ne peux pas vous le dire ah ouais
c'est choquant c'est choquant oui voilà
ça ne parle d'eux pour qui ouais ça fait
des emplois oui
alors heureusement il ya la peluche oui
ah c'est beau ça allait bien alors on
peut avoir une petite chouette petit
couplet torresan ces nations qui la
veille encore dans le commerce s'est
trouvée ils s'étaient vendues en 24
heures est-ce que je suis bête va avoir
sa griffe non elle a ses griffes mais
n'a pas sa grille alors car elle est ou
sheep est pourtant dans les défilés par
exemple vous l'emmenez s'énoncer
c'est moi avec sa femme de chambre soupe
est ne va pas au défilé nous on y va et
pour le défilé de la collection
printemps-été chanel 2018 vous avez
recréer car les gorges du verdon au
grand palais à paris pour rembourser un
décor aussi somptueux pouvant d'au moins
deux robes de la collection non
vous savez on me parle pas de prix donc
je devrais pas ses mots l'hiver ça se
voit c'est magnifique on regarde à quoi
ça ressemble
[Musique]
la collection lier l'augmentation
alors qu'à vos défilés sont de plus en
plus pharaonique alors on se souvient
effectivement de la fusée qui décollait
on se souvient de la tour eiffel on se
souvient du supermarché on regarde
aquasar sens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors car
comment ça se passe vous dites que je
veux les gorges du verdon j'ai une fusée
qui décolle jouer un supermarché les
gens le font les pas de description des
modifications j'adore en nos qualités
c'est un peu ma mère m'a appris une
chose dans la vie il m'a dit voilà que
ce qu'il faut faire l'opinion générale
d'une personne seule
alors toujours sous la verrière du grand
palais vous avez recréer l'atelier de
couture donc ensuite vous aviez fait les
métiers d'art oui au ritz et vous
récidivez car le 6 décembre hambourg oui
vous faites les métiers d'art à la rue
des moulins qui est sublime qui est dans
un endroit extraordinaire je suis né en
fait ça partout en plus pas seulement à
paris et à queue en grèce on n'a pas pu
aller parce qu'ils ont refusé de nous
louer une salle qu'ils ont besoin
d'argent de ces pauvres gens tu es nous
louer leur patrimoine ils ont refusé
doigts et olympe les antennes ans
peut-être pour qu'on ne voit pas quel
point ça mauvais temps
mais alors vous voyager énormément
effectivement vous venez d'ouvrir karl
votre centième boutique en cinq ans oui
c'est que je suis bien entouré vous
détestez en fait prendre l'avion de
ligne parce qu'il faut faire des selles
fille avec les passagers quand on se
déshabille au contrôle les gens vous
photographier dans le pied position de
voilà sache nager paraît bien alors
voyager en avion privé vous dit si on me
donne pas un petit avion je reste chez
moi parce que ce petit petit bon bref
cela prouve au moins comme le désire et
voulait désirer si on veut vous avoir
quelque part dans le monde il faut vous
envoyer un avion vous savez je crois que
c'est diderot qu'il a dit il n'y a pas
d'amour et que les preuves d'amour et
s'ils ont envie eh ben ça se prouve
voilà ça se paye si on va voir
les
[Musique]
assassins
le fils de beauvoisin alors si la photo
est bonne barbara la photo est bonne
c'est en 1987 karl que vous êtes mis
sérieusement la photo et trente ans plus
tard vous êtes l'invité d'honneur de
l'édition 2010 est de paris photo qui
dure jusqu'au 12 novembre donc c'est
demain au grand palais et à cette
occasion vous avez choisi deux cents
oeuvres parmi les photos exposées on va
en regard des quelques
2 peur ils s'envolent une chanson
elle aimait d'aujourd'hui dans le coeur
d'un garçon
[Musique]
hier de paris march des âmes
leur bonheur se construit sur une heure
mais pour eux
sous le pendre
un philosophe
si de musique quel combat depuis les
gendarmes
sous un ciel de paris joue pour soi
revanche entre
les mains d'un peuple est pris de sa
vieille sud est
[Musique]
ça c'est une sélection des photos qui
sont en avait plus de 1000 mais je
choisis deux sangles sont en lice à ces
extraits du livre est ce que je trouve
très intéressant et c'est vraiment
nouveau en photographie fait la
photographie abstraite
oui et ça il ya des choses fantastiques
que moi j'adore ça après tout ça existe
en peinture pourquoi ça n'existerait pas
en photographie bien sûr vous avez dit
aujourd'hui la photographie fait partie
intégrante de la vie elle crée un
mouvement harmonieux entre ma fièvre
artistique et mon effervescence
professionnels s'il n'y a pas de faire
sens quel ennui alors la première photo
qui vous a marqué c'est une photo de
lisa fonssagrives est par irving penn
dans vogue vous souvenez de cette photo
évidemment j'ai même écrit un article là
dessus en avril devait demander à un des
couturiers décrire leurs premières
impressions d'une faute de mode alors
j'ai écrit sur cette faute de peine que
d'un vague américain que ma mère m'avait
ramené d'amérique et tout et tout et
l'article a dû plaire qu'est ce que j'ai
reçu une lettre au bas de la lettre
d'amour de monsieur peine ah oui c'est
bien envie de m elle n'a jamais suivi je
vais dire une chose très prétentieux la
série parce que les autres savaient pas
aussi bien écrit que moi la première
photo de vous en faites dont vous vous
souvenez c'est une photo de victoires
doutreleau en espagnol oui avec un mix
le mineur le rayonnage de saison votre
premier min buri c'est possible je
détiens argent zinc à d'autres j'ai pas
acheté c'est mon père était toujours
demande moi ce que tu veux mais pas
devant ta mère
comment vous faites pour prendre des
photos avec vos bagues et vous et vous
abordez pas de bague il n'y a que lui
qui en a plus y en a plus c'est vrai
vous portez plus bas non parce que j'ai
un problème bizarre en fin d'après midi
mais doit maigrissez et ça fout l'camp
ah oui oui c'est ça toi tu l'avais bague
je débarque sur l'ancienne version mais
mes doigts ne vous donne pas financière
mais bout d'une part il démontre ce
n'est pas pareil
[Musique]
c
alors car vous êtes le roi de
l'aphorisme vous avez le don de la
maxime vous appelez ça les charismes non
vos phrases moi j'appellerai les autres
qui donne ce nom il y en avait bien on
va voir les punchline de karl lagerfel
vous dit il n'y a plus de mode rien que
des vêtements oui c'est un peu vrai pour
regarder des photos des années 60 des
études pareil aujourd'hui et il ya de
tout ouais mon plus grand luxe avez vous
déclaré karl lagerfeld et de n'avoir à
me justifier auprès de personnes et
c'est pas mal ouais vous ai pas de
patron personne que vous voulez je suis
mon propre patron sion vous avez
d'accord à vie avec des grosses sociétés
dont les propriétaires sont des amis
mais la relation patron n'existe pas
puisque je suis toujours conseiller
extérieur même s'il a refait sa le coup
de génie c'est ça c'est à dire qu'en
fait fendi et channel vous avez un
contrat à vis à vis mais vous n'êtes pas
employé non dépend des pas de nain
pointe pas voilà c'est vous le plus
malin quand même non oui mais ça s'est
fait comme ça cette disposition que
regarder si vous regardez le monde de la
mode de jeu de valve s'était déplacé
tout na vi et ça c'est pas concerné
c'est ça vous dit j'aime ce que le
champagne évoque le boire m'endormirai
et oui je peux pas boire d'alcool
demandant tout de suite mais c'est quand
même marrant votre vie parce que tout le
monde imagine que vous buvez que vous
vous droguez non vous faites l'amour
quatre fois par jour et en fait non mais
c'est vrai et en fait je suis un
calviniste un prix de vertu sans mérite
c'est ça donc senti mal à survivre oui
oui c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours à
regarder où sont les autres
les déclarer cela peut paraître bizarre
mais je déteste posséder mais je déteste
l'idée de posséder j'aime trouver
acheter collectionner mais après faut
enfin débarrassé ce qui est fou c'est
que vous vendez si vous achetez achetez
vous auriez aimé cette année avec
quelques donc c'est pas très grand mais
c'est un patrimoine oui quand vous allez
disparaître voulait rien laisser ma
devils pour ça pour disparaître un jour
c'est il ya un champ de mahler qui
s'appelle ifpi navette à prendre comme
samedi pour le monde j'ai disparu et
bien c'est comme ça que je vois je vais
me laisser une trace bistrot non sauf
cargo fun je suis autant admirative
d'ikea de h&m que des marques de luxe ça
aussi c'est un truc à vous dire que vous
êtes allé vers des marques très
populaire à sac et l'a rendue populaire
ouais c'est votre côté andy warhol mais
j'adore ça c'est ça notre époque oui oui
je ne veux pas être dans une tour
d'ivoire isolé dans le grand luxe c'est
pas du tout
créatif c'est très stérile dit je suis
un marionnettiste qui parfois devient
une marionnette c'est à dire que quand
vous venez à la télé vous êtes la
marionnette de karl lagerfeld c'est ça
ou pas avec toi d'accord merci s'est dit
fou
vous dites je me suis créé une image
c'est mon armure c'est vrai oui mais ça
s'est fait naturellement je ne suis pas
si en dix ans alors comment tu vas faire
avec toi quelle tronche tu vas te donne
et nous voilà c'est fait au fur et à
mesure ben oui lui il a un col que moi
je ne porte plus
avait voulu le matin quand je me
réveille je ressemble à beethoven oui
parce que mes cheveux ça fait ça n'est
pas le chien par le chien le compositeur
ah oui évidemment bon je suis mon propre
dictateur de l'exigence c'est ça je vous
connais suffisamment pour savoir que
c'est très exigeant avec les autres ils
abhorrent avec vous même ah oui oui bien
sûr auto facho le tout fait chaud
vous dites alors ils fassent que j'adore
cela plaira à cristina cordula le
shopping est une activité culturelle et
oui à notre époque c'est ça je suis
navré ouais il ya pas de honte à ça
c'est valorisant effet les rênes du
shopping non tu vas tu fais une émission
culturelle sur m6 le sinaï
à
l'étrave j'adore les phrases de cartes
les pantalons de jogging sont un signe
de défaite oui non parce que si on se
laisse à l'élastique est tout ouais
c'est quand voilà il faut mardi costumes
alors il faut il qu'il soit là pour que
ça reste te faire voilà je suis d'accord
avec vous c'est moi je suis d'accord
avec vous je pense que les tatouages
sont horribles c'est comme porter une
robe pucci avis oui j'ai des tatouages
ouais je déteste ça eo2 petite rue
quelque part d'une fleur diamant ça va
dans les jambes qui sont imprimés de
route en bas se trouvent ça d'autant
plus ces gens vont vieillir donc tout ça
va devenir des drapés imprimer
le régime est le seul jeu où l'on gagne
quand on perd c'est vous qui m'avez
donné envie de faire le régiment du
génie l'ancien régime et on ne coupera
pas la tête voilà
avec l'arrêt je suis une sorte de
nymphomane de la mode qui n'atteint
jamais l'orgasme ça sonne vulgaire mais
il ya du vrai là dedans vous savez je
pense que le secret
après sa construction comme vous voulez
c'est que moi je pense toujours que je
suis paresseux qu'on peut faire mieux
donc comme je vis tu vas dans un état de
deux micros novembre personnelle à
l'égard de ma personne c'est très
stimulant c'est gaston ce monfils
question transition vous regarde en est
non pas très beau que les méchants c'est
la bonne marche
des bleus que les défendeurs être
effectif avant l'heure leurs archives et
où je suis contre ça le monde n'est pas
le même donc vous n'avez pas les allons
brûler vos vieilleries je me souviens de
cas la première fois que j'ai
interviewés karl lui dit qu'il avait
gagné le concours de la boule marque
avec un petit manteau en cheville au
john oui il m'a regardé il m'a dit pas
comme les autres lui et vous savez
c'était un concours organisé dans le
monde entier où il y avait deux cent
mille concurrents vrai que ding saint
laurent mais fut avait gagné aussi lui
c'était pour une petite robe c'est
marrant
autre phrase de karl lagerfel mes
lunettes c'est ma burqa mois oui c'est
un peu ça je déteste avoir des
conversations intellectuelle seule ma
propre opinion m'intéresse
mais j'aime être sur un film informer
sur même ceux des lectures les plus
arides et tout mais je n'ai pas envie
d'en parler la tendance si le dernier
stade avant leurs un gars ça veut dire
quoi ça quand ça devienne trop branché
et bien la frontière turin gare n'est
pas loin d'un brave raison
voilà voilà quelques vraies alors là ici
la voix oui
finalement on comprend très bien ce que
dit karl lagerfeld jeu libéré
l'interprète allemand français que vous
m'aviez de louis on peut libérer la
terre pour être alors là la maxime la
punchline la plus terrible c'est la
légende d'un dessin que vous avez publié
dans un journal allemand et au sujet du
million de migrants que angela merkel a
laissé entrer en allemagne ce qui a fait
évidemment monter le vote d'extrême
droite en allemagne et c'est hitler qui
dit merci beaucoup d'avoir par
inadvertance permis à mes descendants
d'être représenté au parlement sont des
cinq fait régulièrement d'ailleurs
dessin dans le frankfurter
tout après des élections et moi je ne
vote pas j'ai failli avoir une attaque
terreur ouais il ya vous savez en 31 il
avait quelques des boutiques où il
n'avait pas avant avec ses vieux in book
est également gaga et puis quelques
années après ils avaient tous les bouts
des stacks appelé reste à évin pas envie
que ça s'appelle comme ça de nouveau
vous dit j'espérais que quelque chose
comme ça c'est à dire l'arrivée des
députés nazis disons un local au
bundestag effet claude blanc j'espérais
que quelque chose comme ça ne se
reproduirait jamais dans ma vie j'ai
honte de l'allemagne même pour moi mais
comme je suis allemand de leurs assumez
vous conséquent gueule à merkel a fait
une grosse faute oui bah mon avis oui
parce que regarder la france qui est le
pays des droits de l'homme et tout ce
qui n'a pas empêché la colonisation
ils prennent ce pas 10000 20000 elle qui
en avait déjà des millions et des
millions qui sont bien intégrés qui
travaille et c'est très bien parce que
de toutes façons de démographie la barre
un peu puissante mais elle n'avait pas
besoin de se taper 1 millions en plus
pour se donner une image charmante après
l'image de marâtre qu'elle s'était
donnée dans l'histoire de la crise
grecque samedi ça tout d'un coup là la
soeur de la fille de pasteur ressort est
ce que crois qu'elle l'a fait pour faire
excuser son attitude pendant la crise
grecque ou pour montrer que l'allemagne
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale ou pour
montrer que l'allemagne était un pays
finalement accueillons oui mais là je
vais d une horreur on ne peut pas et
même s'il ya des décades entre tuer des
millions de juifs pour faire venir des
millions de leurs pires ennemis après
vous savez on demande aux gens de
prendre deux jeunes gens je connais
quelqu'un al malki a pris un jeune
syrien qui parle un peu anglais au bout
de quatre jours vous avez ce qu'il a dit
à la dame savait finalement la meilleure
invention de l'allemagne c'est
l'holocauste ils étaient dans la rue
dans la minute qui suit vous dis tout de
suite
oui l'horreur
non
éloquent
[Musique]
je ne l'est pas kraftwerk voix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vraiment soit 1 1 samedi nous sommes de
retour sur terre toujours en compagnie
de karl lagerfeld
sina candu là d'un squeeze de laurent
baffie
et on passe maintenant à notre thé au
top de la semaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
cristina cordula revanche soir
alors forcément lorsque l'on reçoit
cristina cordula c'est très stressant on
se dit elle va regarder nos vêtements
elle va les juger par exemple moi ce
matin j'avais pas du tout si j'allais
mettre un costume noir ou un costume
noir
et bien finalement j'ai choisi un
costume noir mais bon cette valve
costume noir très bien serré c'est
toujours très élégant n'est ce pas
tarder le costume un nom qui dira le
contraire alors voilà il ya karl
aujourd'hui donc je sais pas si vous
allez pouvoir vous retenir que sina de
lui dire mais monchy rails c'est quoi
ces lunettes 7 quai des cheval et ses
gangs cévennes gard je ne sais pas le
dire ça mais ça va pas ouais ça va pas
répond moi c'est ici on a touché au
summum algérien n'a pas
la garde elle fait moins mal in
effectivement oui alors car vous avez eu
christina comme mannequin pas oui on a
fait beaucoup de défilés c'est un très
bon même qu'un avion était fantastique
ah oui elle est une des premières
brésilienne maintenant il y en a plein
mais à l'époque elle n'avait pas oui
déjà quand je suis arrivé en france
c'est la première maison qui m'a pris
pour faire ses défilés car s'il m'a pris
pour faire des photos je sais pas si tu
te souviens dans l'eau les studios de
madame chanel et pour moi c'était sept
ans voilà c'est mon exemple oscars de la
mode aux connaissances en culture en
internationales ont modernité en ont
l'air dont j'ai bien compris
ok je te la seule personne à avoir pu
relooké cristina cordula c'était pour un
court métrage intitulé the return qui
racontait le retour à la mode de coco
chanel en 1953 c'est géraldine chaplin
qui jouent et channel vous vous
interprétiez le mannequin préféré de
coco chanel qui s'appelait verra valdez
on regarde christina avec un look
complètement différent
[Musique]
puisque miller cities
et voilà donc qui s'inhale jeune nation
grâce à géraldine chaplin vous avez
rencontré correctionnel voilà et être à
côté des géraldine chaplin pour moi
c'était très émouvant et j'ai passé deux
jours incroyables avec la maison avec
car avec tout le monde avec l'équipe les
petites mains c'était pour moi retourner
dans quoi j'étais mannequin et ça
vraiment c'était très émouvant pour moi
nos biens donnés ces petits films ça
m'amusait le faire mais au bout de deux
jours j'allais assez donc tout doit
s'est passé très vite mais j'ai fait
tout le décor dès le dialogue les
costumes je fais tout moi-même sinon ça
m'embête je m'intéresse parce que je
fais moi
alors certes c'est drôle de voir quoi
que c'est comme ça moi je préfère la la
coupe playmobil pas son but jadas
marella y faut savoir qu'on arrête on
est dans le temps c'était super et tout
un travail on a des heures avec la
théorie que le maquillage non c'était
formidable de noé pied essayez le
vêtement dès l'époque où j'étais j'ai
été nommé je te rappelle se souvient pas
est-ce que tu parles comme un vieux t'as
vu non pas du tout c'est quand même tu
te rappelles karl may était kaunas
ce que j'avais
là vous aviez abandonner votre fameux
scoop en fait qui nous a rendus célèbres
parce que vous êtes venu star le jour
vous avez été sept coupes de cheveux
karl lagerfeld et toi vous êtes tous les
lieux devenus des logos dont karl c'est
la silhouette évidemment s'il doit être
très mince de kato meilleur on appelle
logo fait voilà qu au fait vous gecina
c'est la coupe court les créoles le
rouge à lèvres qui aujourd'hui est un
peu moins violent que ce qui pourrait
être
trop alors vous avez en commun tous les
deux de vivre en france depuis des
années est de toujours avoir gardé notre
accent alors est ce que c'est pour avoir
le plaisir d'être imités moi je ne sais
même pas de ce que j'ai comme à l'accent
fait nationalement la légère il neigeait
très léger
karl est facilement évitable avec son
action les limitations dalle explique ce
qui est absolument extraordinaire oui
mais c'est quand même pas papy fait de
la résistance et par cet accent là on va
regarder parce que avec givet génial
quand il vous dit on regarde cette bio
c'est incroyable le nombre de petites
boutiques où les bonnes femmes vont
acheter en étant persuadé qu'elle
s'achète du 38 sachet de au moins 46
mannequin c'est à dire du cros j'adore
la maigreur
je trouve ça fantastique la mode est
fait pour la maigreur vont arrêter de
raconter n'importe quoi la mode est pas
fait pour des énorme patate
un petit tour de passe passe
de terminer j'ai une petite culotte
pour polly pocket
book finale des jo 2008 et aux
infections c'est ludivine valandraud qui
vous imitent très très bien alors voilà
on la voit là si ça se trouve c'est vous
non c'est vrai que c'est moi je me
demande si vous faites pas des
animations dans des centres commerciaux
et comme nous assumer pas vous fait
croire que ça se joue
c'est finalement son bois mon nom et son
frère il était chez moi à la mer
alors sur m6 tout va bien la robe de ma
vie revient tous les lundis à 22h55 ans
le pitch ces deux femmes qui sont guidés
par des proches et par des vendeurs et
qui cherche la robe de leur rêve pour le
plus beau jour de leur vie oui pour pour
beaucoup de femmes la robe de mariée
c'est vraiment un vêtement très spécial
c'est pas une mission de conseil ont
fait non pas du tout en fait c'est une
émission où ça se passe avec plusieurs
marié la future mariée elle va dans une
boutique de robes de mariée et elle va
choisir sa robe donc je donne pas de
doute conseil je commente cette histoire
mais la robe de mariée si tu veux ce
n'est pas vraiment important de ce qui
est important c'est ce qui ressort de
l'art de marier tous les côtés
psychologique donc et a par exemple
marié qui veut aller chercher sa robe de
mariée avec sa mère et elles sont en
plus avec sa mère et elle trouve que les
prétextes de trouver la robe de mariée
va ça peut les approcher donc c'est
toute cette histoire entre eux qu'est-ce
qui la mer en passe de la robe et puis à
des bagarres il ya des pleurs des rires
et a beaucoup d'amour et puis à la fin
c'est plus une émission de télé réalité
qu'une jeune coaching c'est entre
guillemets en télé réalité parce que ben
ils suivent tous les gens ont peur car
c'était un an après vous vous commentez
et le fait d'être actrice vous permet
d'avoir du recul de la navy tance de la
psychologie de l'analyse merci laurent
voilà ça nous donne un peu de recul par
rapport à ce que vous faites d'habitude
est ce qu'il y aura des mariages gay a
bien sûr j'espère bien gelé car il y
aura des solos gamme à solo de gamme
jeremstar il s'est marié avec lumen
alain delon car les marier avec lui-même
on peut dire car les vraiment l'exemple
du soul gamme est un peu content
sioniste pour la nuit de noces oui bah
oui dsk au ras du sol ghana je pense pas
non non on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
cette nouvelle saison nous avons revu
nos caméras dans des boutiques de robes
de mariée
geneviève c'est la surprise du chef ils
se disent on va arriver les tous
nouveaux coups de coeur
[Musique]
oui et magnifique son histoire match
parce que la belle
mais les larmes de papa je crois que ça
vaut toutes les normes jours
le nouveau coût 10 quand je rentre dans
la boutique là je me dis c'est une
blague ça déjà pas l'algérie un canton
qui moi je pense que la totalité de la
rom ne lui convient pas aux puits même
derrière se doit cette vous dis non
c'est trembler les nuls moi je n'aurais
pas bruyamment défilé
sûrement qui a 15 ans il ya 15 ans
d'autant qu'elle dise que je regarde
c'est vous
dire que c'est beau alors que ça
ressemble à ça je ne sais jamais si on
ne peut pas nier haut de ses 25 ans se
comportait comme ça moi je dis non elle
est belle la robe nettoie
les plus inattendus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce que vous avez lu cette musique à
votre mariage n'a pas choisi mode 500 l
amie mylène farmer sans contrefaçon je
suis un gars très possible disait vous
êtes marié aussi christina bas là on
voit là une de gala
l'heureuse élue s'appelle frédéric
il a demandé votre main le 14 février
2016 avec une sublime bague panthère en
diamant de chez cartier une dmla de la
mignonne christine a répondu
immédiatement oui
en même temps c'était le proviseur qui
demandait
il
et
le trésor le tombeau
j'ai fait des cérémonies de mariage dans
trois pays différents il ya eu singapour
c'est là où frédéric est basé ensuite il
ya eu capri c'est la ville de leur amour
parce qu'ils vont se sont tous les ans
via rio parce que c'est beau de ville à
vous alors à rio vous êtes mariés alors
sur un héliport qui a été aménagé pour
l'occasion c'était magnifique
il unit tout pour le tout
hé hé
à
noter on pousse tous quel bonheur quand
boehner
alors pour les sourcils vous avez fait
comment sur sa molesse en salle mais mon
sens elle s'était déjà préparé ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que pour christina
ressources à elle c'est super important
lesourd salsa va pas je n'existe pas
c'est pas l'être humain n'est pas comme
ça j'ai fait un appel national en france
on laisse aux salles bien sèche ne faut
pas les sources al trion dans la tête de
son style c'est la catastrophe
sur sign on dit ça doit vous faire
hurler nom
des millions ça on a essayé de voir
quand même comment ça vous irait les son
style
à 7 millions pour le faire
et
maintenant on passe un autre tu es qui
toi de la semaine
m
regard
alors squeeze re bonsoir
alors la meilleure façon de vous
présenter c'est de commencer par dire
que vous avez 9 millions d'abonnés sur
votre chaîne youtube et que vos vidéo
totalise 4 milliards milliard de vues
j'imagine déjà veulent nous faire
bizarre de découvrir un vieux média qui
s'appelle la télévision vous êtes
méchant avec vous même quand même sinon
on est mort
vieux qui regardent la télé non pour moi
les deux doivent exister en fait on
trouve des trucs sur youtube qui a pas
la télé inversement donc ouais enfin moi
ya pas de guerre ou quoi pour votre
génération de la télévision c'est un
téléphone géant qu'on peut pas emporter
nous on va quoi ces encombrants c'est un
peu ça je peux pas hanter la télévision
ça va arriver je pense pas mais la
police pense que les deux doivent
vraiment la télévision linéaire où on
dit aux gens il faut être à sept heures
du soir devant le poste pour voir salut
les terriens c'est mort ouais mais on
retrouve sa hausse et sur youtube on dit
aux gens tel jour telle heure sur une
vidéo venez sur youtube sur ma chaîne
donc finalement il s'est un peu la même
soirée oui moins pessimiste que moi sur
l'avenir de télévision complètement
complètement pas du tout pessimiste sur
l'avenir de la télévision moi même ça
m'arrive de regarder mon commentaire
surtout vous regarde tous les
documentaires un mec comme debout bon
état
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable c'est le roi de youtube
etc et il est ici ce soir pour faire la
promo d'un livre finalement vous êtes
assez old school ouais on peut voir ça
comme ça mais bof à nous penser qu'ils
vont acheter un livre de vous si
j'achète un lit vos fans c'est un tapis
de souris pour renault
il peut faire tapisserie à l'hiver alors
votre livre s'appelle tourner la page
vous aviez peur que vos fans soit
incapable de savoir comment ça
fonctionne un lit déjà et ensuite c'est
aussi une petite référence aux vidéos
sur youtube qui ont des titres un peu
aguicheur ça me faisait marrer de
reproduire la même mécanique mais au
format livre avant de parler de votre
livre vous expliquez pourquoi vous êtes
un génie
le temps j'ai dit parce que votre boulot
consiste à vous filmer en train de jouer
à des jeux vidéo et elle diffusée et les
gens vous regardent jouer et comme il ya
de la pub voulaient de l'argent je dois
dire bravo belle et beaucoup d'argent
mais 480000 euros par an on c'est vrai
je gagne beaucoup d'argent mais ce
chiffre est faux alors ils ne gagnent de
l'argent oui il faut savoir que ça gagne
énormément d'argent pour vingt personnes
si le prise depuis longtemps ma
exactement où vous exactement mais
faisant manquer aussi beaucoup de gens
qui marchent beaucoup moins bien et qui
ont du mal à vivre de ça en fait mais
l'orgie mélenchon a du mal c'est devenu
un métier donc en 2010 est de regarder
des jeux vidéos de les commenter est-ce
que manger des pizzas c'est devenu un
métier
d'avenir
vous devriez faire ça c'est fait j'ai
bouffé des pizzas sur youtube et les
gens viendraient me voir manger au japon
il ya beaucoup de demain comme ça ils se
filment en train de manger et ça fait de
l'audience alors excusé si vous filmez
en faisant d'autres trucs par exemple
lire dormir baiser ça marche non alors
ça serait la télé réalité on se rabaisse
pas si vous vous regardez des jeux vous
n'avez pas en fait deux il ya un peu de
tout sur le net d'emploi de catégorie il
ya aussi des gens qui vont parler de
mode comme christina par exemple des
gens qui vont jouer aux jeux vidéo comme
moi des gens qui vont faire des sketchs
comme cyprien des gens qui ont parlé
d'histoire comme nota bene fin il ya
vraiment de tout et moi je ce que je
fais surtout c'est de l'humour en fait
ensuite je me sers des jeux vidéo pour
faire rire ou alors juste déballé des
objets du japon par exemple récemment
avec des potes et on va filmer ça et
dynamiser tout au montage et pour
regarder vraiment les dix meilleures
minutes et voilà alors désormais en
publiant nos enfants que s'ils passent
leur temps à regarder les jeux vidéo ils
vont jamais trouvé de travail oui c'est
vrai on va regarder à quoi ressemble
votre travail squeeze
écoutez j'ai écouté j'entends la biche
j'entends labiche passé
je sais où il est c'est parti
[Musique]
via sa filiale à bull est là qu en bas
faut faire attention à deux choses en
même temps c'est ça qui est dur et en
plus faut toujours par le même temps à
tout bout lui tard il imite les hommes
c'est incroyable énorme blague de boxe
bien sûr abonnez vous
[Musique]
un génie on en a vu des branleurs dans
l'émission monsieur l'allemagne est la
seconde étape mais tu aimerais gaubert
avait commencé avec le gaming ou vous
commenter avec humour aux parties de
jeux vidéo et puis j'avais
progressivement diversifié vos activités
et multiplier les podcasts sur votre vie
personnelle en fait au début les gens
voulaient se ranger dans une catégorie
c'est à dire moi je veux faire du jeu
vidéo moi je vais parler beauté au moins
je vais parler de menuiserie et
maintenant en fait c'est juste des gens
qui partagent leur passion et tu vas le
raconter des histoires donc c'est
vachement diversifiée en fait alors de
cliquer squeeze s'appelle tourner la
page avec la participation de maxence
lapérouse illustré par florent au chat
essai publié chez michel lafon il ça
sort le 16 novembre alors vous dites que
ce livre est destiné aux gens qui sont
stressés qui sont angoissés fait les
gens qui regardent les réseaux sociaux
on peut penser qu'ils sont tous comme ça
un peu il y en a pas mal mais non c'est
surtout une blague en vrai il détenait à
je pense aux ados et aux jeunes adultes
et en fait c'est un livre dans lequel tu
vas devoir dessiner tu vas devoir
découper ou des fois il aurait juste des
blagues des petits jeux et moi j'ai
envie de faire un livre qui me plairait
un mec comme moi qui n'aime pas
énormément mais en fait j'aime ce qu'il
ya autour du livre mais j'ai pas été
sensibilisés à ça quand j'étais plus
jeune et j'ai jamais fait l'effort de
lire des livres fut un peu scotché sur
les écrans c'est un peu cliché mais
c'est vrai du coup j'ai fait un livre
que qui me plairait à moi en fait
justement en réunion alors voilà la télé
c'est nul et c'est un gars mais on n'a
rien trouvé de mieux pour donner aux
gens envie d'acheter un livre d'accord
avec ça si une vidéo sur youtube ça
marche mais merde
mais c'est quand même sympa d'en parler
à la télé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo et merci
voix
après la bulle avec l ennemi se ride
jamie soir me samia maktouf avocat né
dans un milieu modeste devenu une star
du barreau défend aussi bien
alors il dit l'église en chine sur eux
comme j'ai attaqué dit
ben ali actu
[Musique]
soirée à miami nous sommes de retour sur
terre toujours en compagnie de karl
lagerfeld
cristina cordula d'un squeeze non ma
fille est maintenant mesdames messieurs
c'est l'heure des infos de vise haut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que pkp ce soir thierry bonsoir
bonsoir à tous on attaque avec la
politique française
pour 50% des français il est trop tôt
pour juger emmanuel macron pour les 50
autres pour cent des français il serait
trop tard pour ne pas élire emmanuel
macron cela étant n'attendez pas trop
parce que là par exemple il est trop
tard pour juger jacques chirac
emmanuel macron toujours il aurait
renoncé à célébrer les 50 ans de mai 68
et c'est peut-être mieux comme ça
demandé à emmanuel macron de célébrer
mai 68 c'est aussi décalé que demander à
tariq ramadan de célébrer la journée
internationale de la femme
[Applaudissements]
et passons à cette information les
députés français sont parmi les mieux
rémunérés d'europe il ya que les
allemands qui sont plus loin j'ai fait
un petit graphique pour voir une idée
avec nos voisins alors voilà la belgique
la l'italie l'espagne et la suisse et on
y ajoute la france
et ça vous donne une idée je vous laisse
interpréter le message humaniste que
nous avons à nous élus
et sans transition c'est laura flessel
la ministre préférée des français une
jeune femme noire depuis qu'il a pris
connaissance de cette information eric
zemmour est en réanimation
laura flessel qui cette semaine a
proposé que la marseillaise puisse être
chanté avant chaque match de championnat
de france sauf au paris saint germain où
on chantera bien sûr le leem deux cas
paris mais quand même l'hymne national
français à chaque match du côté
d'ajaccio et de bastia on est très
soulagés de ne plus être en ligue 1
[Applaudissements]
gouvernement toujours
nicolas hulot abandonne l'objectif de
réduire le nucléaire de 50% d'ici 2025
après avoir cédé sur les perturbateurs
endocriniens et sur le glyphosate alors
le jour où on parviendra à transformer
les rétropédalage de nicolas hulot en
énergie on pourra fermer toutes les
centrales nucléaires de france
politique en accord avec cette étrange
info bernard cazeneuve ancien premier
ministre socialiste est régulièrement
pris pour eric ciotti député les
républicains et inversement en même
temps il fallait pas s'attendre à ce
qu'on les prenne pour brad pitt les 2
mai
je vous donne le petit truc pour les
différencier c'est pas très compliqué
canin qui est de droite et l'autre qui
est encore plus de droite façon à
ségolène royal elle salue le leadership
du chef de l'état la dernière fois
qu'une femme a fait autant de lèche à un
président en exercice c'était monica
levinsky
politique et mode ça va vous parler à
tous les deux françois fillon a été
approché par une marque de prêt-à-porter
masculin pour lui proposer de participer
une campagne de publicité françois
fillon mannequin chouette plus
sérieusement qui imagine le général de
gaulle faire une campagne de pub si je
vous ai compris c'est grâce à mon
appareils auditifs audika ça ne
fonctionnerait pas
je vous promets terry c'est ma dernière
imitation de la semaine passons à ce
gros dossier de la semaine fiscalité les
parades à sp perth nouvelles révélations
sur les milliards des paradis fiscaux
c'est la grosse info de la semaine moi
personnellement j'ai du mal à le croire
thierry apparemment donc il ya des gens
qui préféraient payer moins d'impôts et
ça m'a déstabilisé alors bon résultat on
s'est tous fait un peu baiser mais
heureusement un homme a parlé un homme a
parlé pierre moscovici exige une liste
noire des paradis fiscaux d'ici la fin
de l'année mais mais c'est contre
ce type n'est jamais été ministre de
l'économie
si on me dit que oui il l'a été deux ans
par wee a et depuis 2014 il est
commissaire européen à la fiscalité
ça c'est quand même marrant parce que il
a tweeté cette semaine les révélations
des paradise peppers sont vertigineuses
le monde opaque de l'évasion fiscale
apparaît soudain au grand jour c'est
donc la surprise la plus mal joué depuis
la réaction d'anne hidalgo à l'annoncé
de l'attribution des gens à paris
[Applaudissements]
parmi les personnalités du showbiz un
nom parmi d'autres est tombé cette
semaine jean jacques annaud il aurait
soustrait son argent au fisc via un
trust aux îles cayman son avocat l'a
défendu en des termes étrange monsieur
anoh et bon cinéaste mais pas excellent
fiscaliste et c'est assez génial comme
défense l'avocat de polanski devrait
tenter romanet bon réalisateur mais pas
excellent baby sitter et sage pour tous
jawad est bon logeur mais pas excellent
organisateur de spectacles vivants
société
cet hiver en france des mesures
exceptionnelles de restrictions
d'électricité pourraient être prises on
parle notamment de coupure pure et
simple d'électricité alors ou peut-être
voir la bonne nouvelle la bonne chose
thierry peut-être c'est que après noël
la famille de vincent lambert ne devra
plus avoir de raison de se disputer
sempé
éjaculer au moins 20 fois par mois
participent à la bonne santé de la
prostate ne lâche rien et et arrêtons de
stigmatiser les branleurs compulsif
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses il ya des
gens très bien dans l'administration
française donc arrêtons de stigmatiser
les branleurs compulsif ce sont juste
des hypocondriaques vertus
[Applaudissements]
santé encore au japon une entreprise
offre six jours de congés de plus aux
non fumeurs mais que les fumeurs ne
s'inquiète pas eux aussi évidemment ils
auront beaucoup de temps libre en arrêt
de travail pour aller à leur chimio les
brèves
toulouse elle confond une bouche de
métro avec une entrée de parking et
c'est sans doute un peu de la même
manière qu'a été inventé la sodomie
et cette semaine comme chaque semaine je
vous emmène dans un lieu culturel je
vous emmène à montpellier à la panacée
où a lieu la rétrospective de jacques
charlier un artiste belge autodidacte
hauteur de peintures de dessins et de
photos détournées première grande
rétrospective de cet artiste belge en
france voilà alors notamment cette photo
qu'on pourrait renommer et jacques
faciale chez les teletubbies mais
jacques charlier est devenu un artiste
en trouvant une photo d'un champ
betteraves dans une poubelle il
travaillait alors au service technique
de la province de liège et où il voyait
des chantiers des routes des sites
abandonnés et il a notamment exposé
toutes ces photos on va en voir
quelques-unes il faut torres et vilaine
qui l'appelle paysage professionnel on
va en voir d'autres un des photos qui ne
sont pas sans rappeler les films des
frères dardenne et et puis et puis il a
fait des tableaux il a fait des tableaux
on voit celui-ci notamment apparemment
un portrait de john fitzgerald kennedy
un autre on va le voir qui nous emmène
dans la tête de laurent wauquiez quand
on lui demande les points forts de son
programme
et passons à cette oeuvre si baptisé
raclée aux vinyles alors oui c'est
clairement l'image d'un couple dont
l'homme a acheté le dernier album de
kenshi girac
[Applaudissements]
super ouais c'est l'aisance et c'est
super et c'est très drôle il ya toute
une série qui s'appelle peinture
cannibale or ici voilà c'est plutôt
balance tombeboeuf du coup mais on peut
voir sur les morceaux il ya des
étiquettes avec l'écrit et jennifer
lopez britney spears et même si on joue
et bien il y en a une lui a écrit
nolwenn leroy maintenant à comme quoi
laurent baffie n'est pas le seul à
considérer comme un morceau de viande
non non non non c'est cadeau c'est
cadeau il aime aussi pastiche et
d'autres artistes qui étaient là avant
lui notamment le pop art ici les facs de
liechtenstein comme on le reconnaît ici
l'oeuvre s'intitule vraiment omar a pété
même bigard est posée celle là est sa
série la plus connue qui devait
représenter la belgique lors de la
biennale de venise en 2009 a été refusée
pour son caractère sexuel il s'agit de
100 sexes d'artistes et voilà il
pastiche sens artistes qu'il admire
notamment jeff koons voilà barème est à
croire jacques charlier jeff koons ne
savait pas enfiler une capote il ya
cristaux aussi évidemment connu pour
emballer des oeuvres ceci représente un
petit show mais toutes les féministes
voudrait faire harvey weinstein
je termine par mon oeuvre préférée de
jacques charlier c'est un portrait de
philippe geluck avec en dessous écrit
chaque jour la belgique change la france
et je serai mal placé pour contredire
cet hymne modestie je vous dis à la
semaine pour accomplir
[Applaudissements]
et
joe wright
la semaine prochaine sur scène et en
tournée dans toute la france
car la guerre telle merci merci d'avoir
été avec nous c'est un plaisir vraiment
de vous à vos propres à chaque fois que
nous
[Applaudissements]
et voilà en face maintenant un autre
terrienne du samedi soir
[Musique]
samia maktouf bonsoir
alors je tenais en tunisie vous êtes
devenue avocate au barreau de paris et
de tunis la france vous a découverte
lors du procès d'abdelkader meira où
vous défendiez latifa himdi athènes mais
vous ne défendez pas que des victimes
puisque vous avez plaidé pour ziad
takeddine où l'épousé de ben ali leïla
lens amiens vous racontez votre
extraordinaire parcours dans un livre
intitulé je défendrai la vie autant que
vous prêchez la mort c'est publié chez
michel lafon et puis ce soir dans salut
les terriens et en hommage à tunis
[Musique]
il
samia maktouf via quatre souches
en tunisie
le 30 septembre
1963 votre père était économe dans un
hôpital votre mère était femme au foyer
à l'époque la ville de sousse était
assez cosmopolite y avait une communauté
juive une communauté italienne une
communauté musulmane et tout le monde
vivaient en parfaite harmonie à l'époque
c'est à fait c'était ça la richesse que
malheureusement aujourd'hui on ne
retrouve moi et moi j'ai découvert des
conflits ont l'arrivant sur le
territoire français mais pas dans ma
tunisie natale alors quarante jours
après votre naissance vos parents
déménagent à tunis où vous grandissez
dans un environnement très masculin vous
avez cinq frères c'est difficile de se
faire respecter quand on a cinq frères
d'objets donné des coups de poing pour
gagner votre liberté très jeune en fait
pour vous faire admettre dans la famille
l'exemple à suivre c'est l'aîné qui
s'appelle lotfi à lotfi toujours premier
de la classe
très doux et très en avance il vous fait
dire le monde fait regarder les dossiers
de l'écran sur antenne 2
il nous a beaucoup aidés à progresser
nous a tracé le chemin quand vous
parliez tout à l'heure d'abdel kader
meira et
d'autres délinquants le chemin ne leur a
pas été tracées dans ma fratrie où nous
avons été élevés dans le respect de
l'autre le modèle à suivre était le
frère aîné iam deux frères évidemment le
dfi il ya aussi le centre culturel
français vous apprenez prout voltaire
montesquieu
tout à fait c'est parce que je suis
arrivé en france j'avais déjà lu les
livres qui qui s'imposent regardez les
films
et côtoyé la culture des siècles des
lumières alors l'autre fille va être
avocat et vous dit pourquoi pas moi et
bac en poche ou fait droit à la faculté
de sow puis 1 sorbonne alors vous venez
d'un milieu très modeste donc vous devez
financer vos études vous même samia vous
fait des petits boulots alors vous êtes
en troisième année de droit quand vous
entamez un stage au cabinet de l'avocat
théo klein vous l'avez eue au culot
ensuite il va falloir démontrer que vous
n'êtes pas juste bonne à faire des cafés
mais une avocate on devenir le premier
contact avec ce métier c'est un jour il
ya l'héritier d'une dynastie
riches et célèbres qui vient de se
pendre dans sa salle de bain la veille
de son mariage et vous y allez tout à
fait j'étais chargé de représenter mon
maître de stage et c'était le premier
contact avec le son avec la détresse
humaine et c'était terrible mais il
fallait que je reste de bouger j'ai fait
un effort pour ne pas tomber dans les
pommes et depuis je suis debout alors
après un stage à new york que vous
découvrez le métier d'avocate d'affaires
alors pour nous ici en france avocat
d'affaires c'est un terme extrêmement
péjoratif
vous découvrez pour les anglo saxons
c'est pas un problème
on suit donc vous entrez dans l'un des
plus célèbres cabinet d'avocats parisien
et qui s'appelle gilles vous êtes 20
stagiaires
boutry mais dans les sous-sols
alors un soir vers 20 heures un associé
descendre dans la cave où il ya tous les
stagiaires et il cherche quelqu'un qui
peut travailler sur du droit polonais
vous vous dites moi
il était minuit je n'avais aucune idée
sur ce que pouvait ressembler le droit
polonais mais je me suis proposé parce
que
parce que j'avais envie d'être là y de
répondre présentes et le lendemain nous
quitter le sous sol vous avez été
tellement brillante sur le droit
polonais que tout le monde dit elle est
exceptionnelle j'ai fait la recherche
j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire parce
que je dis toujours que un bon avocat
c'est celui qui sait où trouver et
comment trouver donc voilà et en 1995
vous prêter serment et vous donner
rapidement si vous êtes aujourd'hui
c'est à dire une grande avocate alors
vous défendez des clients célèbres
évidemment mais vous défendez aussi des
gens comme leila ben ali la femme du
dictateur tunisien qui est attaqué dans
un livre s'appelle la régente de
carthage donc ce sera un avocat c'est
l'honneur de notre robe on en a parlé
très récemment dans le procès nairas
l'honneur de ma robe était d'accepter de
défendre non pas la femme d'un dictateur
mais la femme qui a été attaqué
sur des éléments qui était fallacieux
c'est ça un avocat et je n'ai
strictement rien à regretter c'est
l'honneur de notre europe sur les bancs
du giat takieddine donc été impliquées
dans le volet financier de l'affairé
karachi vous parle du financement de la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy par kadhafi
là vous parlez à l'avocate que je suis
donc je n'irai pas plus loin alors vous
défendez évidemment takieddine leila ben
ali mais vous défendrez aussi des
migrants est devenue la sainte patronne
des migrants votre numéro de téléphone
tourne dans les camps de migrants
parfois il est affiché dans les centres
de rétention c'est à dire que un jour
dans le palais de justice vous y arrivez
des migrants des vous ça vous fait un
choc quoi toute assez écoutés c'est
peut-être au lendemain de la révolution
en tunisie et je ne pouvais pas rester
insensible j'ai mis entre parenthèses
pendant six mois ma vie professionnelle
au sein du cabinet pour me consacrer
intégralement à led au soutien et à
l'assistance de ces migrants parce que
voyez ces migrants ça pouvait être un de
mes frères ça pouvait être un voisin ça
pouvait être n'importe qui les mêmes qui
débarque au cabinet sans rendez vous il
tape ils savent que c'est la bonne
adresse à fêter vocalia semaine c'est
d'un et un jour il ya un jeune tunisien
de 15 ans qui n'est pas un migrant fait
qui frappe à votre porte son père à
payer un passeur pour le faire venir en
france vous vous êtes en colère vous
demander d'appeler son père en dix ans
appelle-t-on perd franchement ça se fait
pas venir en france sans autorisation et
là vous découvrez en écoutant son père
qu'il est victime d'une leucémie rares
et que c'était sa dernière chance en
fait pour lui c'était la mort où
l'embarcation et il a survécu et grâce à
des associations françaises france terre
d'asile il a pu être scolarisé il a pu
apprendre la langue française et il est
aujourd'hui un homme respectueux de la
république française
et puis en mars 2012 c'est moi-même
nairas qui reprend une phrase de ben
laden mois la mort je laime comme vous
aimez la vie d'où le titre de votre
livre je défendrai la vie autant que
vous prêchez la mort alors c'est vous
qui convainque est en fait de la
nécessité de réintroduire l'autorisation
de sortie du territoire pour les mineurs
qui voudraient quitter le pays cesser
votre action je trouvais ça abominable
je trouvais que les politiciens et gelé
j'assume mes propos sont à côté de la
plaque lorsque en 2012 en la nuque dans
le cadre de simplification de modalités
pour le citoyen français on annule pêle
mêle plusieurs dispositions dans
l'autorisation de sortie qui devait être
donnée par les parents et pour cela il
fallait que le parent se déplace à la
mairie pour signer est bon on a trouvé
que c'était une perte de temps pour les
parents et on l'a tout simplement annulé
jusqu'au jour où la maman de branne jeu
plus jeunes mineurs qui a quitté la
france se retrouve en train de partir
pour renforcer l'armée de dèche depuis
la ferme ra vous défendez beaucoup de
victimes d'attentats terroristes
victimes du bataclan mutile de nice
je voulais être là la voix de ses
victimes ces victimes qui n'ont pas de
voix aujourd'hui je les vois je les
côtoie aucune victime aucun parent de
victimes ne ressemble à un autre parent
de victime c'est terrible et c'est maman
la ont perdu leur fils tout simplement
parce que la france était ciblé parce
que dans la firme ra c'était des
militaires s'étaient nos militaires et
c'était aussi notre enfance qu'on a tué
parce que ces enfants qu'on a tué myriam
et les autres on les a tuées parce que
il était juif ils étaient de confession
juive et nous sommes en 2017 et on
continue à tuer parce que on est
militaire parce qu'on est des comptes de
confession juive c'est intolérable et on
peut pas l'accepter
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est aussi
intolérable
ce sont les gens qui vous appelle pour
expliquer que la ferme est rare est
monté de toutes pièces dans les services
secrets français que le 13 novembre a
été organisée par le mossad et par la
cia c'est dingue côté je voudrais vous
remercier de m'avoir posé cette question
parce que vous savez c'est très très
répandue ce n'est pas une exception
c'est pour ça qu'il faut continuer à
rester debout c'est pour ça qu'il faut
continuer à se battre il n'y a pas un
moment il n'y a pas une semaine qui
passe sans que j'entends de cette
version et vous savez cette version je
l'entends parce que je suis musulmane
injures et parce qu'on me dit b ou
voyance amiens vous vous savez c'est des
sionistes qui ont monté ça et vous savez
il faut qu'on le souligne parce que
c'est très grave parce que la société
est encore truffé de moi mais de mera
d'abdel kader nairas des kwasi d'abba
woods de fabien klein de toute cette
mouvance terroriste qui a permis à moi
mais de mera de tirer sur la gâchette
pour tuer les militaires et des enfants
juifs mais le socle le socle signé
encore justement vous dit
finalement le coran qui est vendu à la
fnac
c'est un coran qui a été trafiqué par
les années les américains pour modifier
la religion musulmane alors vous me
donnez l'occasion de le dire clairement
et sans ambiguïté que le procès
d'abdelkader meira n'était pas le procès
de sa religion ça n'a strictement rien à
voir avec l'islam et madame l'avocate
générale dans ce procès l'a très bien
défini elle a parlé de la famille meira
en disant que c'est un monument
d'antisémitisme c'est un monument de
haine et de violence l'islam n'a
strictement rien à voir avec ça soyons
honnêtes est ce que dans les familles
musulmanes aujourd'hui qui vivent en
france est ce qu'il n'ya pas une culture
antisémite est ce que dès le plus jeune
âge c'était pareil en france dans les
années 30 c'est pas une critique du
monde musulman dans les années 30
c'était pareil en france quand quelqu'un
était petit il avait l'habitude d'être
élevée dans une ambiance antisémite et
quand il ya eu la guerre de 39 ça n'a
pas étonné que la france envoie des
juifs dans des camps de concentration
les premières victimes de
l'endoctrinement du terrorisme sans les
musulmans
ce dont on parle aujourd'hui c'est une
minorité de musulmans qui veulent
répondre ce mais c'est ce cancer qui
veulent répondre cette haine mais ils ne
vont pas réussir ils ne le feront pas
parce qu'on sera tous face à eux
vous défendez la famille dit nadia thème
donc et pendant le procès le regarde
d'abdelkader merav ou fusils pour lui
une vraie musulmane ne peut pas plaider
contre les siens je suis une apostats
pour abdel kader meira mais je ne me
retrouve pas je ne me reconnais pas dans
cet islam ce n'est pas de l'islam dont
il parle c'est d'une secte c'est une
idiotie gic qui veut donner la mort ce
que abd el kader meira a dans les yeux
c'est la mort c'est la mort et c'est
celle ci qu'il veut répandre dans notre
société lorsque il s'adresse au
président de la cour en lui disant je ne
reconnais pas votre loi je reconnais la
loi d'allah alors que il bénéficie de
tout ce que la république lui a offert
il est né français il est plus français
comme l'un des quatre derniers mois j'ai
j'ai eu l'honneur d'obtenir ma
naturalisation et j'en suis fier je suis
fier de cette double appartenance
tunisiennes et françaises
abdel kader berra aînés en france et ne
parlez pas l'arabe il est allé en egypte
pour apprendre l'arabe et il a prétendu
se convertir à l'islam
à quel islam il s'est converti à la
haine à la déchéance humaine
cc vous savez le seul moment le seul
moment que je voudrais en tant
qu'avocate retenir de ce procès qui
marquera l'histoire
c'est un seul instant
c'est celui où l'ensemble des parties
civiles se sont succédé à la barre pour
parler
ce jour là les parties civiles nous ont
donné une leçon de dignité une leçon de
courage ce jour là le seul moment où
un nerf d'humanité a régné sur la cour
d'assises et puis arrive le verdict
abdel kader mehr a été acquitté de
complicité mais condamné à 20 ans pour
association de malfaiteurs est ce que
vous êtes satisfaite du verdict bien sûr
que non bien sûr que non parce que
abdelkader meira et bien l'instigateur
et bien la tête et les bras de moi mais
de mira c'est le chef d'orchestre c'est
le mentor c'est celui qui avait de
l'emprise et ça ça ne vient pas de moi
ça vient du dossier qui fait plus de
cent dix sept mille tome on a regardé
latifa xi athènes
c'était trop dur
trop dur
je pense qu'on est trop naïf et qu'on
doit ouvrir les yeux
c'est pas ça que j'attendais mais moi je
vais rester debout
ensuite combat pour est destitué dé ce
qui tombe dans cette secte dangereuse
et j'espère qu'ils me font mal
et dont les membres des dieux qui dieu
jugera les avocats de marc à
j'espère qu'il sera jugé
et tous les soirs ce qui suit d'or et
passa toute cette famille qu'est ce que
la france est trop naïve la france est
trop naïve vous savez madame vous y
était né au lendemain de 2012
elle a dit il y a beaucoup trop de mera
beaucoup trop de meira on m'a appelé on
m'a contacté on m'a dit on comprend la
douleur de votre cliente avoir perdu un
enfant c'est très dur et c'est très
pénible mais c'est pas pour autant qu'il
faut alerter l'opinion publique
malheureusement il s'est avéré qu'elle a
eu raison parce que moi mais de meira a
enfanté beaucoup d'autres meira
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on voit que
abdelkader meira a
écopé de vingt ans pour
association de malfaiteurs terroristes
et que ces mêmes éléments auraient pu
servir pour retenir la complicité parce
que vous savez soit le dossier vide
et auquel cas il aurait fallu écouter
dupond moretti est acquitté
abdel kader meira soit le dossier
contient les éléments nécessaires pour
retenir la complicité donc 20 ans ça
veut dire dans dix ans dans dix ans à
des cadets remera est dehors et
malheureusement d'autres personnes bien
sûr question a jugé abdel kader mais
ramon a pas jugé la toile d'araignée les
personnes endoctrinés radicaliser qui
veulent que le
l'islamisme régente la société c'est le
plus grand mal qu'on puisse faire à
l'islam parce que comme l'a expliqué et
la diagnostiquer le poète et l'écrivain
franco tunisien abdelwahab meddeb c'est
ça la maladie de l'islam l'islam doit se
confiner dans la sphère intime la
religion quelle qu'elle soit doit
demeurer dans sa sphère intime la
société ce n'est pas cela la laïcité
c'est le respect de toutes les religions
et ce n'est pas la négation d'autres
religions merci
votre show du samedi soir avec à
je suis non
oui
tout seul
via cette émission a devant
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in a
l'habitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu